raw sewage being pumped into the sea at
Bexhill
well this is just one of the many
Outlets where raw sewage is is pumped
out and it's in Rachel's backyard for
the last six months she says she's seen
more here than ever floating sewage raw
raw sewage
and a clear difference in the shades of
the water as well so closer to the
Shoreline it's just murky filthy and it
stinks and flies actually flying above
the surface of the water as well where
the sewage is
while some Rivers were affected to
beaches across England and Wales were
closed this week due to released sewage
this map shows mostly green ticks now
meaning the water's safe but look at
what was found here a beach rated good
all week and this scene in tankerton a
few days ago where it's still not safe
to swim this one stretch of sand has had
50 pollution alerts so far this year
water companies are allowed to release
sewage when sewers are at risk of being
overwhelmed at bexil the water was being
regularly tested I've just spoken to a
lifeguard here who says that the red
flags have now been taken down because
the pollution levels are now deemed to
be safe but he's not personally
recommending it to people who ask him
because he says not that long ago it
still just didn't smell right
in a statement Southern water said more
rain than usual has overwhelmed our
Network this led to some overflows which
are used to protect homes schools
businesses and hospitals from flooding
spilling excess water into the sea these
discharges are heavily diluted we are
dedicated to significantly reducing
storm overflows
Wendy's a community scientist monitoring
waste along the coast a regular swimmer
but still refuses to go in it's not just
going to float along the surface and
disappear out to sea it's surely it's
got to permeate into the sand and into
the sort of surrounding Beach
because you've got a high tide and a low
tide so surely it's going to wash in and
out Cliff's kayaking business has also
suffered as a result of sewage dumps
this weekend's bookings in the sea
canceled we've lost thousands over the
last two years where we've had to cancel
sessions we've been on the water with
groups we've had to come in as the
sewage has come out and we've seen it
will be told by the lifeguards bexil is
officially open and safe but on a
Saturday in August in the school
holidays it's near empty not many are
willing to risk it Adele Robinson Sky
News